Sandy Deason: Well, thank you for being here.
My name is Sandy Deason and I'm part of the
Authors @ Google program and we are very excited
to have Mark Danner here today.
Just to give you a little history.
For the past two decades, Mr. Danner has reported
from Latin America, Haiti, the Balkans, in
the Middle East.
His perceptive award winning dispatches have
not only explored the real consequences of
American engagement with the world but also
the relationship between political violence
and power.
Now today I got feedback from Googlers that
they wanted the talk to be focused on torture
and where we are when it comes to extreme
interrogation with the Obama Administration.
So he'll be talking about his book "Stripping
Bare the Body" but also he will focus his
talk on that issue.
Please remember if you have any questions
to go to the mic over there so that when it's
on YouTube, people will hear the questions
and without further ado, here's Mr. Danner.
Thank you very much.
[applause]
Mark Danner: Thanks very much.
Thank you, Sandy.
It's a pleasure to be at Google and thank
you to Ann Farmer for inviting me and thank
you all for coming.
I thought I would talk today - as Sandy mentioned,
I've been out talking about my current book
which is called "Stripping Bare the Body:
Politics Violence War.
This is Ann Farmer's copy. [laughs]
I'm going to say a word -- start by saying
a word about the title and then we'll talk
a little bit about one aspect of the book
which is about torture and the Bush Administration
and now the Obama Administration.
And then we'd love to take questions on whatever
subject.
I've written about Haiti, Iraq, the war on
terror, a lot on torture for the last six
years.
The book is called "Stripping Bare the Body",
as I said, which comes from a quotation from
a former Haitian president, Leslie Manigat.
He is a very interesting guy -- intellectual,
political exile, supporter of Duvalier, the
Haitian dictator, autocrat.
And he told me in an interview he served as
President for about five months before he
was overthrown in a military coup, as many
Haitian presidents are.
And he told me in an interview in which we
were talking about my preoccupations, what
I like to write about, he said, "Political
violence is like stripping bare the social
body. The better to place the stethoscope
and hear the real life beneath the skin."
According to this view, which I share, if
you really want to understand a society, if
you want to see what makes it tick, the forces
that are raging beneath the surface, who's
up, who's down, who has power, who's trying
to get power, what it's real values are, then
look at that society during a time of stress,
a time of violence, a time of revolution,
a coup d'état, civil war.
Look at that society in the months and years
after it's been attacked by terrorists, for
example.
So this book essentially is a kind of compendium
of what Mantigat calls "these moments of nudity",
in his phrase.
It begins with a long section, reporting section,
reporting on the ground from Haiti in which
it describes the chaos after the fall of Duvalier
and the attempt to build a democracy in Haiti,
an attempt that is still going on that led
to all sort of dislocations, violence, political
instability.
That's the section that's really about the
late Cold War.
It goes on then to a substantial section reporting
on the Balkan Wars of the early 90's.
We knew that era at the time is the post Cold
War world -- a very weird name - it's like
calling non-fiction, calling something by
what it's not.
As we look back on it now, even though at
the time, people were talking about the end
of history.
The Cold War is over.
We've now reached a nirvana of democracy and
capitalism.
But as we look back on that period now, we
must just as well call it "the age of genocide"
because there were two large genocides, one
in the Balkans, one in Rwanda, in which the
West, self described West, basically looked
on and did nothing and watched it on television,
watched both of them on television.
And finally, the last part is about Iraq and
the war on terror and there's a good deal
of reporting from the Iraq War on the ground
from Fallujah, from Baghdad, particularly
later parts of the war.
There's a good deal of reporting about the
US during the war on terror.
And finally, this is what I'd like to talk
to you about today, a lot of writing on torture.
The writing on torture is under the general
category, what I call the "state of exception".
What is the state of exception?
It's a broad term under which you can group
martial law, state of emergency, state of
siege, and it really indicates that we're
living in a kind of separate time now -- soft
martial law if you will, that was declared
in the days and weeks after the 9/11 attacks
and that we still have not exited from.
It's not just the war on terror itself but
the sets of laws and changes in the law that
the Bush Administration introduced to essentially
build a different governing consensus on issues
like wire tapping.
Right now, the government can essentially
tap your phone calls and read your emails.
It's a complicated issue of course but they
can do it without court approval and that
was begun under the Bush Administration that
continues under the Obama Administration.
Extraordinary rendition is another aspect
of the state of exception in which people
are picked up off the street in foreign countries,
kidnapped, taken to a series of so called
"black sites", secret prisons around the world,
where they're interrogated and sometimes tortured.
And then just the general issue of torture
itself and harsh interrogation.
Torture is a long story, of course.
It began in the days and weeks after 9/11;
it is with us still.
It's interesting, deeply interesting from
my point of view, because I've been covering
it as a journalist now for six or seven years.
I published a book in 2004 called "Torture
and Truth" which essentially, from Google's
point of view, I guess it's kind of a retrograde
book because it consisted of two thirds of
it, about 400 pages, consisted of government
documents, which were published and which
were released in the wake of the Abu Gharaib
scandal.
You'll all remember those photographs, which
told in very great detail the story of how
the US, after 9/11, made the decision to torture
detainees or to use extreme interrogation,
which is the preferred term of the Bush Administration
and the Republican party -- how those decisions
were made, how the program was developed,
how the protocol of how the interrogation
was done was developed within the CIA and
also the Defense department, how it was approved
by the Department of Justice, what those legal
documents were.
And I published them in that book that declared
that torture was legal and this goes back
to 2004.
The first large, large scale piece on torture
was published in the Washington Post in December
of 2002, followed by - that was about 4,000
to 5,000 words front page, followed a couple
of months later by a piece equally long in
the New York Times.
So, one of the strange things about the torture
story from the beginning is that there is
the story of what happened, that is how this
protocol was developed, who was interrogated
in this way, what the CIA did and what the
Department of Defense did, what the Department
of Justice did, all these things which we
know a lot about.
And there's a parallel narrative and that
parallel narrative is what we knew about it,
and the fact is though as a journalist and
a writer, I fall easily into the kind of rhetoric
of disclosure.
When was this disclosed?
When was the revelation?
When did it happen?
In fact, we have known the better part of
this story for a half dozen years and it's
one of the peculiar things, which I call in
the book "the frozen scandal" -- the notion
that - what I believe certainly to be wrongdoing
is made public.
It is generally acknowledged by most people
to have happened and yet it continues.
I grew up and earliest came to political consciousness
in the Watergate period when you had a kind
of sequence of events that defined a scandal.
First, you'd have revelation, usually by the
press but often by a leak in the press.
Next, you'd have investigation - societal
investigation by the Congress, by the courts
sometimes but an investigation that would
give you a story of what happened that society
could agree on.
And finally, you'd have expiation.
People would be prosecuted, they'd lose their
jobs, they'd be punished in some way, the
society would return to some kind of what
might be called "a state of grace", I guess.
One of the things that seems to me that characterizes
our age, the age of the war on terror, is
that process, that three-fold process, that
three-part process, has been derailed.
We're stuck between revelation and true investigation
and that's where we are with torture.
Torture has gone from being an anathema as
it was before the war on terror to being essentially
a policy choice, and also to being a political
football.
I brought along yesterday's copy of the New
York Times, hard copy, front page, "Groups
Attack on Justice Department Lawyers, Divides
Conservatives".
Did anybody see this, this piece?
Very interesting piece essentially about the
fact that you have this
Republican political group that has now demanded
the names of what it calls the "terrorist
lawyers" -- the Al-Qaeda Seven is the other
phrase, which are the lawyers supposedly within
the Obama Justice Department, that have represented
detainees in court.
So this has now become a permanent part of
our political system, the argument over torture
and the argument over terrorism.
People compare this to McCarthyism.
I would say it's a fairly good comparison
but the fact is that embedded in our political
system now is an argument about terrorism
and torture in which torture has taken on
a very different role.
The Republican party at this point has a fairly
unambiguous position on torture which is that
they support it.
They call it extreme interrogation techniques,
EIT's, but they very much believe that this
should be used on terrorist suspects.
They're angry and attacked the Obama Administration
for not having used these techniques on the
so called "Christmas Bomber", the "Underwear
Bomber" as other people call him, and torture
has become a kind of badge of commitment.
Do you have the determination to protect the
country?
Are you willing to do whatever it takes to
shelter Americans from terrorists?
And if you're not, you're essentially in favor
of coddling terrorists.
It's become a permanent part of our political
discourse.
Let me just tell you a little bit about what
I'm talking about when I talk about torture.
I want to read - last Spring, I published
a document "The Red Cross Report" which was
essentially an interview with 14 high value
detainees, HVD's, people who'd been arrested
mostly in Pakistan and Afghanistan - captured
I should say, not arrested and taken to the
black sites I mentioned which were secret
prisons that were established in well, Pakistan,
Afghanistan, Thailand, Morocco, Poland, Lithuania,
Romania, Diego Garcia.
There are probably several others we don't
yet know about but these were places that
were completely secret where these people
were taken off to for interrogation.
I want to read a little bit about what this
kind of interrogation is like and I'm going
to use an excerpt from "The Red Cross Report"
that I published last Spring.
It's the account of Abu Zubaydah who was the
first of the so called "big fish", high valued
detainees.
He was captured in Pakistan in March 2002
-- so not even six months after 9/11.
He tried to escape, he was shot three times,
bled very badly, went into a coma.
The CIA and the Pakistanis who grabbed him
thought he was going to die.
They secretly shipped over from Baltimore
an American trauma surgeon who stitched him
up.
He went into a coma and the account I'm going
to read is him basically waking up from this
coma.
He's the first on who these techniques in
aggregate were tried, one after the other.
This is Abu Zubaydah, 33 years old of Saudi
and Palestinian descent.
"I woke up, naked, strapped to a bed, in a
very white room.
The room measured approximately 13 feet by
13 feet.
The room had 3 solid walls, with a fourth
wall consisting of metal bars separating it
from a larger room.
I'm not sure how long I remained in the bed.
After some time -- I think it was several
days, but can’t remember exactly -- I was
transferred to a chair where I was kept, shackled
by the hands and feet for what I think was
the next 2 to 3 weeks.
During this time I developed blisters on the
underside of my legs due to the constant sitting.
I was only allowed to get up from the chair
to go the toilet, which consisted of a bucket.
Water for cleaning myself was provided in
a plastic bottle.
I was given no solid food during the first
two to three weeks while sitting on the chair.
I was only given Ensure", which is a kind
of canned nutrient drink, "and water to drink.
At first the Ensure made me vomit, but this
became less with time."
It should be said here he had no idea where
he was, where exactly this white room was
located.
"The cell and room were air-conditioned and
were very cold.
Very loud, shouting type music was constantly
playing.
It kept repeating about every fifteen minutes
twenty-four hours a day.
Sometimes the music stopped and was replaced
by a loud hissing or crackling noise."
Now what we're seeing here is a series of
so called protocols.
This is the conditioning phase of the interrogation.
He's kept naked; the technical name for this
for the interrogators is 'adjustment of clothing
to induce stress'.
The room is kept extremely cold, probably
in the low 50's Fahrenheit.
All of this is specified in the CIA documents.
In fact there's an agent who's detailed basically
to watch him and make sure he doesn't turn
blue because blue indicates hypothermia.
Use of noise to induce stress, that's the
constantly playing music.
All of this of course together is supposed
to result in, among other things, sleep deprivation.
The final attribute here is a stress position
and when it comes to Abu Zubaydah, we are
talking about long term sitting so for three
weeks or possibly more he's kept shackled
in precisely the same position, day and night,
constantly.
After Abu Zubaydah, who is the first of these
main guys, they switched to long term standing
in which they shackled prisoners with their
wrists shackled to the ceiling, their feet
shackled to the floor.
And again, they're naked.
They're in a very cold room and they are kept
like this for several weeks.
And if you want to feel what that's like,
put your hands over your head for five minutes
so that's a "stress position", quote end quote,
in the euphemistic language.
The CIA protocol describes "As the HVD, high
value detainee, is placed in the vertical
shackling position to begin sleep deprivation.
Other shackling procedures may be used during
interrogation.
The detainee is diapered for sanitary purposes",
so he doesn't have to be released to sit on
the bucket or whatever, "although the diaper
is not used at all times" and indeed they
frequently took this off so they had to urinate
and defecate on one another – on themselves,
sorry, and then they would throw water on
them.
[pause]
Well, just a word about the standing stress
position.
This is Khalid Sheikh Mohammed, who we've
heard a lot about, who was supposed to be
tried in New York.
Now it is unclear where he is going to be
tried.
"I was kept for one month in the cell in the
standing position with my hands cuffed and
shackled above my head and my feet cuffed
and shackled to a point in the floor.
Of course during this month I fell asleep
on some occasions while still being held in
this position.
This resulted in all my weight being applied
to the handcuffs around my wrist resulting
in open and bleeding wounds.
Both my feet became very swollen after one
month of almost continual standing."
The person who took the testimony remarks
at this point that indeed there is significant
scarring on his wrist and on his ankles. Now,
it's important to remember that long term
standing - it seems like a very simple "Okay,
keep him standing" but one thing about torture
is very simple techniques are extremely effective.
This was a Soviet technique, which the CIA
studied.
The Soviets called it shtoyka, simply shtoyka,
and it has, after a couple of hours, extremely
dramatic physical effects.
The CIA report on it from the late 60's, I'll
just read a sentence: "After 18 to 24 hours
of continuous standing, there is an accumulation
of fluid in the tissues of the legs.
This dependent edema is produced by the extravasation
of fluid from the blood vessels."
In other words, water is coming out, all kinds
of fluids is coming out of the arteries.
"The ankles and feet of the prisoner swell
to twice their normal circumference.
The edema may rise up to the legs as high
as the middle of the thighs.
The skin becomes tense and intensely painful.
Large blisters develop which break and exude
watery serum."
So, for this reason, you had frequently a
doctor coming in while Khalid Sheikh Mohammed
was standing with his hands shackled to the
ceiling, who would use a tape measure on his
legs to see how much they had swollen.
Okay, let me continue for a minute with Abu
Zubadayah, our first detainee.
This is several weeks later after the first
phase which is called the conditioning phase.
"Two black wooden boxes were brought into
the room outside my cell."
Remember, the cell is 3 walls and then there
are bars, okay?
"One of these wooden boxes was tall, slightly
higher than me and narrow, measuring perhaps
in area of 3 1/2 by 2 1/2 by 6 ½ feet in
height."
So it's like a standing coffin basically.
"The other was shorter, perhaps only 3 1/2
feet in height" -- so a box like this.
"I was taken out of my cell; one of the interrogators
wrapped a towel around my neck.
They then used it to swing me around and smash
me repeatedly against the hard walls of the
room.
I was also repeatedly slapped in the face.
I was then put into the tall black box for
what I think was about 1 1/2 to 2 hours.
The box was totally black on the inside as
well as the outside.
They put a cloth or cover over the outside
of the box to cut out all light and restrict
my air supply.
It was difficult to breathe.
When I was let out of the box, I saw that
one of the walls of the room had been covered
with plywood sheeting.
From now on it was against this wall that
I was smashed with the towel around my neck.
I think that the plywood was put there to
provide some absorption of the impact of my
body.
The interrogators realized that smashing me
against the hard wall would probably quickly
result in physical injury."
That plywood I've thought a lot about and
one can say a couple of things about it.
One is that the problem of torture is -- how
do you inflict enough pain while keeping the
person who's being interrogated healthy enough
to be interrogated?
You don't want to cause permanent or disabling
injury.
So when he was walled -- this is called 'walling';
that is towel placed around the neck, smashed
repeatedly against the wall.
Clearly the interrogators saw that they might
break a bone.
It's important to remember that each of these
procedures, wherever they were happening -- and
it's probably Thailand, we don't know for
sure as he didn't know -- each of these procedures
were approved specifically by at least the
Deputy Director level of the CIA.
So you had constant back and forth by email,
by cable saying. "Can we do this, can we do
that, can we wall him?"
Though I don't have the documents to prove
it, I have a suspicion that after they tried
walling the first time, which is something
that the Israelis use to use as well and which
gradually developed over the course of these
interrogations.
Eventually the towel was replaced by a leather
collar which actually had handles that the
interrogators could use to smash them.
The first time they used it I have a hunch
that the interrogators thought, "God, we're
going to break this guy's arm or break his
leg."
They wrote back to headquarters and they were
told to do something to dampen the effect
and they put the plywood up.
The other thing to remember here is that not
only were these things approved specifically
at the top level of the CIA but the director
at the time, George Tenet -- we are talking
about 2002 here -- would travel sometimes
several times a day to the White House to
brief the Principles Committee on what was
going on in these interrogations.
And the Principles Committee is Secretary
of State, Secretary of Defense, National Security
Advisor, Attorney General, Vice President,
and sometimes the President.
So when we talk about torture and prosecutions
and things like that, investigations, it's
important to remember that this stuff happened
and responsibility was spread fairly widely
at the top levels of the government, I think,
for specific reasons.
I think the CIA was quite determined that
at a time when this stuff is exposed and they
knew it would be exposed, that they were not
going to be the ones holding the bag, or to
use a child's game analogy, they are not going
to be the ones without a chair when the music
stopped.
So they made sure not only the Department
of Justice approved these techniques specifically,
they also made sure that while they were going
on people at the top levels knew about them,
even when by the way, they didn't want to.
John Ashcroft, the Attorney General, is quoted
in one of these meetings saying, "We shouldn't
be talking about this in the White House.
History will not deal kindly with this."
All right.
We don't have a lot of time so let me just
read the last section here from what happened.
All right, the box.
Well, let me skip the rest of the box.
The point is he started to bleed from these
wounds.
Umm, all right.
I should say for those of you who are interested
in the subject, there's an awful lot of material
available about these interrogations and it's
been confirmed by other accounts.
Okay, the last from Abu Zubadayah:
"They placed a cloth or cover over the box
to cut out the light and restrict my air supply.
As it was not high enough to sit upright,
I had to crouch down."
This is the 3 1/2 foot box.
"It was very difficult because of my wounds.
The stress on my legs held in this position
meant my wounds both in the leg and stomach
became very painful.
I think this occurred about 3 months after
my last operation.
It was always cold in the room, but when the
cover was placed over the box it made it hot
and sweaty.
The wound on my legs began to open and started
to bleed.
I don’t know how long I remained in the
small box, I think I may have slept or maybe
fainted.
I was then dragged from the small box, unable
to walk properly and put on what looked like
a hospital bed, and strapped down very tightly
with belts."
There was a belt across his chest, ankles,
wrists.
"A black cloth was then placed over my face
and the interrogators used a mineral bottle
to pour water on the cloth so that I could
not breathe.
After a few minutes the cloth was removed
and the bed was rotated into an upright position."
So this is a sort of a hospital gurney that
can go all the way down and all the way up
to vertical or horizontal.
"The pressure of the straps on my wounds was
very painful.
I vomited.
The bed was then again lowered to horizontal
position and the same torture carried out
again with the black cloth over my face and
water poured on from the bottle.
On this occasion my head was in a more backward,
downwards position."
Remember this is the first time this is being
used.
"And the water was poured on for a longer
time."
So his head is down like this, feet up like
that, strapped, and he's naked of course this
whole time.
"I struggled against the straps, trying to
breathe, but it was hopeless.
I thought I was going to die.
I lost control of my urine.
Since then I still lose control of my urine
when under stress.
I was then placed again in the tall box.
While I was inside the box, loud music was
played again and somebody kept banging repeatedly
on the box from the outside.
I tried to sit down on the floor, but because
of the small space the bucket of urine tipped
over and spilled over me.
I was then taken out again.
A towel was wrapped around my neck and I was
smashed into the wall with the plywood covering
and repeatedly slapped in the face by the
same two interrogators.
I was then made to sit on the floor with a
black hood over my head until the next session
began.
The room was always kept very cold.
This went on for approximately a week.
During this time the whole procedure was repeated
five times.
On each occasion, apart from one, I was suffocated
once or twice."
He means the waterboarding on the hospital
bed.
"And was put in the vertical position on the
bed in between.
On one occasion the suffocation was repeated
three times.
I vomited each time I was put in the vertical
position between suffocations.
During that week I was not given any solid
food."
Obviously, they didn't want to lose him when
he vomited which is part of this procedure.
"I collapsed and lost consciousness on several
occasions.
Eventually the torture was stopped by the
intervention of a doctor.
I was told during this period that I was one
of the first to receive these interrogation
techniques, so no rules applied.
It felt like they were experimenting and trying
out techniques to be used later on other people."
That is in fact true.
We see during the course of the various accounts
of these interrogations how these techniques
evolve.
I mentioned the towel which became a leather
collar and then a plastic collar that was
developed specifically for walling prisoners.
The waterboarding technique, which we've just
looked at, evolved more and came to involve,
among other things, an oximeter, placed on
the prisoner's finger or thumb so as to constantly
monitor vital signs so again to not lose the
prisoner, to not have him die under interrogation.
So we can see if you look at these documents
an evolution of what happens.
Now, it should be said he says, "I'm the first.
They were experimenting on me."
It should be said these are very - what I've
described to you are very old techniques.
They go back centuries, literally.
Waterboarding goes back at least to the Inquisition
and -- depending on how you define it -- probably
farther.
The French used it in Algeria.
They would generally strap a prisoner.
They beat him up as here, naked, strap him
down usually on his back to a bench of some
kind, lift the bench up, and submerge his
head in a bucket of liquid.
Sometimes dirty water, soapy water, urine
sometimes.
The point is to have it go back into the lungs
basically and it produces a choking, drowning
sensation.
The press in describing this, the boiler plate
is often "simulated drowning" they call "waterboarding"
but there's nothing really simulated about
it.
It's drowning.
You could call it really "interrupted drowning".
Anyway, we see a steady progression of these
techniques.
A development of them and they were used on
hundreds of people; we don't know how many
specifically but certainly the numbers in
the hundreds.
They were used across the government.
I've been reading from accounts of the CIA,
which are kind of purest, as it were, version
but the Department of Defense used them in
Guantanamo.
Mr. Qahtani, among others, and various other
parts of the government did as well.
So, why talk about them now?
Well, as you know when President Obama took
office, the second full day of his Presidency,
he signed three executive orders.
Among other things, they stopped these specific
techniques and limited what the CIA could
do to what is included in the Army field manual.
A field manual that was reissued in 2006 specifically
prohibits most of what I've just described
to you although there is a very significant
loophole in that which I don't really have
time to get into but he did indeed declare
that this would stop.
He declared also that the government would
do a study on proper interrogation and finally
he declared that Guantanamo would be closed
within a year.
As we all know, Guantanamo has not been closed
and indeed it's unclear when it might be.
Greg Craig, who was the official - Obama's
White House Counsel, the
official most closely associated with this
policy, has lost his job, probably due to
his advocacy of this.
And we've seen during the past year a remarkable
phenomenon which is a push back on the part
of the Republicans in general but especially
the former Vice President in a kind of unprecedented
- I just don't
know anything in American history that is
like it.
Within ten days of Vice President Cheney leaving
office and Obama assuming the Presidency,
the former Vice President was out criticizing
the Administration for having renounced torture.
I'm going to read a quote from him.
This is ten days after he left office on - I
think this is on Fox television.
This is Cheney: "When we get people who are
more concerned about reading the rights to
an Al Qaeda terrorist than they are with protecting
the United States against people who are absolutely
committed to do anything they can to kill
Americans, then I worry.
These are evil people.
We’re not going to win this fight by turning
the other cheek.
If it hadn’t been for what we did, with
respect to the enhanced interrogation techniques
for high value detainees, then we would have
been attacked again.
These policies we put in place, in my opinion,
were absolutely crucial to getting us through
the last seven plus years without a major
casualty attack on the United States."
And he has made these sorts of statements
repeatedly and they have become more and more
truculent, more and more aggressive, until
you reach the point where he talks about - this
is a couple of months later last Spring where
the terrorists are - he warned of an attack
where "the terrorists are armed with something
much more dangerous", I'm quoting, "than an
airline ticket and a box cutter - a nuclear
weapon and a biological weapon of some kind.
That’s the one that would involve the deaths
of perhaps hundreds of thousands of people,
and the one you have to spend a hell of a
lot of time guarding against.
I think there’s a high probability of such
an attempt."
The Vice President went on, "Whether or not
they can pull it off depends whether or not
we keep in place policies that have allowed
us to defeat all further attempts, since 9/11,
to launch mass casualty attacks against the
United States.
If you release hardcore Al Qaeda terrorists
who are held in Guantanamo, I think they go
back into the business of trying to kill more
Americans and mount further mass casualties
attacks.
If you turn them loose and they go kill more
Americans, who is responsible for that?",
asked the former Vice President. Who indeed?
These statements have been extremely effective
I would argue in pushing the Republican party
to see the political gains to be made by using
that most lucrative of political emotions,
fear, and they have done it extremely well
so that by now, a year after 9/11, we've seen
major attack on the Administration over the
so called "Underwear Bomber".
And we've seen a general development of the
idea of torture as necessary to protect the
United States.
And in fact it seems to me, if we get back
to "Stripping Bare the Body" here for a minute
and the body we are stripping bare is our
own country and our own values, that one of
the most egregious results of 9/11 has been
the belief on apparently a majority of the
population that this country cannot be kept
safe if the government follows the law.
The figures now on torture, among Americans,
on the feelings about torture among Americans,
are quite striking.
The most recent Pew poll, if you look at the
numbers simply of those people in various
countries who will say yes to the question,
"The government should never torture detainees".
That's the question you ask and you say, "Do
you agree with that?"
In Egypt, for example, 53 percent say yes,
the government should never torture detainees.
In Iran, 56 percent say yes, the government
should never torture detainees.
In Palestinian territories, 66 percent, two
out of three.
Europe roughly, depending on which country,
around 80 percent so four out of five say
the government should never torture detainees.
Americans - does anybody want to guess?
>> 25.
Mark Danner: Very good.
That's precisely right.
25 percent of Americans say the government
should never torture detainees and I would
argue to you that this does not define a difference
between Americans and all other peoples.
It basically is a product of the rhetoric
that we have seen coming out first from the
Bush administration
[audio cuts off for almost two minutes]
[applause]
Mark Danner: Anything?
I've answered all your questions, eh? [laughs]
>> Thank you for coming.
One of the things I'm interested in is how
did the idea of not trying the terrorists
in a civilian court - why is that such an
issue now?
Because I know that under Bush they did try
a lot of terrorists in civilian courts and
so why is it such an issue now?
Mark Danner: That's a great question actually.
After 9/11, the Bush Administration put together
a strategy that was very much based on defining
the war on terror as a war, and in part there
was a political motive for this, a couple
of political motives.
One was to separate them from the Clinton
Administration.
They never declared war, they never took this
seriously which in a sense could combat the
notion that the Bush Administration had let
the country be attacked.
They were politically vulnerable, they were
aggressive about it.
Also defining it as a war allowed the President
to increase his power to the utmost degree.
We're now in a war, we're now in a crisis.
I can wiretap, I can interrogate beyond the
bounds of the law, I can imprison five thousand
immigrants in the US on my own authority so
they have this interest in doing it this way
and the Military Commissions idea was a part
of that.
The problem was the Supreme Court knocked
it down several times.
Congress then reinstated it and went back
and forth but your question was very intelligently
posed because it is true that during this
whole time the civilian courts continued prosecuting
terrorists, very effectively by the way.
The Military Commissions, because of all these
problems with how they were defined, I think
they at the end of the day prosecuted three.
I believe that's the right number.
In civilian courts, hundreds.
Why has it become a big issue now?
Because I think it fits into this general
political motive that I tried to define that
the Republicans have which is to be aggressive
on the war on terror, to say that the Obama
Administration doesn't take it seriously and
doesn't believe it's a war, and of course
trying terrorists in civilian courts fits
into that perfectly.
Why aren't they using Military Commissions?
Why did they read the Miranda rights to the
so called "Underwear Bomber", right?
How could they do that?
This fits also, it should be observed I think,
into the general Republican rhetoric about
tough on crime.
This dove tells very well with the kind of
domestic rhetoric of Miranda rights, coddling
prisoners, coddling criminals so it fits very
well into Republican terminology and Republican
politics.
>> Can you clarify who all is affected by
these policies?
'Cause as you mentioned, when Cheney gets
on TV or one of these extremely anti terrorist
people or whatever get on TV, they say, "If
we can't interrogate the terrorists, the Al
Qaeda people, then we're gonna lose the war."
But in fact in implementing these policies,
it seems that it certainly doesn't only affect
the Al Qaeda terrorists.
If for some reason, I was misidentified as
a terrorist, they could come and pick me up.
So can you clarify who all is affected and
what percentage of the population could in
theory be interrogated and so on?
Mark Danner: Well again, that's a really good
question.
It should be said, I think first of all, that
there are about 150 or 160 prisoners still
in Guantanamo.
But at one time there were 800 and most of
those people have simply been released.
Some of them released to foreign governments
and they're in jail.
But most of them were simply released because
certainly the majority of those prisoners
should not have been there.
They were handed over to American forces in
part because the Americans offered a bounty
of a thousand dollars on up for any terrorist
who was captured and handed over to them.
So hundreds of people were handed over to
them and the Bush Administration knew quite
early on that most of those people didn't
belong in Guantanamo.
But the political cost of releasing them were
quite high and it was much easier to keep
them which is a horrible thing but it's documented
and true and I write about this a little bit
in my book.
They actually developed a so called "mosaic
theory of information" whereby it didn't matter
if they were terrorists.
"If we can get enough information from them,
we can put all of this into a mosaic and still
learn about terrorism."
I mean this was actually a remarkable thing
whereby basically the idea of having to arrest
only terrorists was kind of defined out of
existence.
So we also have, on the rendition side, which
is something I mentioned earlier.
This kind of snatching people, kidnapping
them, and taking them to black sites.
A number of very highly publicized cases,
the most highly publicized is Maher Arar who
was a Canadian citizen of Syrian descent who
was grabbed on a flight to Europe at Kennedy
Airport, whisked away to Syria where he was
tortured for a year in very horrible ways
and it was a complete mistake.
It was just a mistake.
They had a different person.
The Canadian government, to its great credit,
did a full investigation of this -- the report
again you can find very easily.
It's quite thorough and fascinating.
The American government, on the other hand,
has never admitted that's a mistake or in
the case of any of these other prisoners.
So I think you're right and the broader point
that needs to be made here is when you don't
have due process, mistakes get made and are
not corrected.
I mean, mistakes are made all the time but
if you have an adversary process, if you have
courts, if you have lawyers, they can be corrected
because someone is there arguing.
But if you are just throwing someone into
a dungeon, which in effect you are here, there's
is no adversary process and indeed even when
you find out what's wrong, that this person
shouldn't be there, there's no incentive to
fix it.
In fact, there's a disincentive because it's
embarrassing.
The other thing finally that should be said
is that one of things that happens, and this
happened in Iraq which I saw, you know at
Abu Ghraib for example, they arrested so many
people.
They did these sweeps - in the early days
of the insurgency when the US had no good
intelligence on what was going on, they would
just cordon off a neighborhood and smash -- break
down doors, and arrest every young man they
could find.
No evidence, they would just take them.
These combat units would just take them and
this is again a documented fact.
They would be sent to Abu Ghraib so Abu Ghraib
at a certain point had 15, 18, 20 thousand
prisoners, 90 percent of whom and that figure
comes from the intelligence agencies, should
not have been there.
One of the things it did was break down the
intelligence process.
The interrogators had so many people to interview
and were wasting their time so much and could
not release them because the combat units,
who had a say in who was released, resisted
it and you had a completely dysfunctional
system.
So in practical terms, it also screwed things
up very well, not just in justice terms.
So, who does it affect?
I mean, it affected a lot of people it shouldn't
have affected, no question about it.
Yes?
>> Hi, I'm not sure where to start. I've had
outrage fatigue for eight years.
Mark Danner: Yeah.
Well, I know the feeling.
>> But unfortunately, it hasn't abated and
I'm trying to ask this in a constructive way.
What do you think we could actually fix that
would make a difference?
And the thing that comes to me is just the
unreality - the turning on reality into policy
and I don't know any - there's like 'Dirty
Harry' who gets people angry because some
criminal didn't get read his Miranda rights.
And then there's Glies quoting '24' saying
this is turning into reality.
And then just general Fox News.
They're just complete non reality.
How - would a return to the Fairness Doctrine
help?
Mark Danner: Now you're depressing me. [laughs]
Well first of all, thanks for bringing up
'Dirty Harry'.
I often raise 'Dirty Harry' and '24' which
I think is its spawn in a way because these
do put forward a kind of ideology which is
that liberals with their red tape and all
this law crap, they're going to get you killed.
And what we need is some tough men to cut
through that and protect the country. And
'Dirty Harry' is in San Francisco of course
and Clint Eastwood is a rogue cop, that is
his superiors want to punish him and he cuts
through it all and he tortures the serial
killer on the 50 yard line of Kezar Stadium
as I recall; it's still a remarkable movie
but he's a rogue cop in the system.
The interesting change with '24' is that Kiefer
Sutherland - the character Jack Bauer is employed
directly by the White House, by the President.
The unit, or whatever it is, is a direct emanation
of the White House itself circumventing all
the red tape and so on.
And apparently this idea, and this is why
it works politically, when the population
is fearful and this rhetoric creates fear
first, you create it, they are about do another
mass casualty attack and then you respond
with the answer which is we have to be tough
as nails.
We have to cut through all this stupid law
stuff and do whatever is necessary and that
nation of untrammeled power protecting is
apparently a very, for many people, a very
calming notion.
When you get to your question which is about
what to do about it, as I say, you were starting
to depress me in talking about the Fairness
Doctrine.
I think it is true that the deterioration
and the quality of television news in particular
makes this kind of rhetoric more effective.
You have Fox yelling and yelling about and
you also by the way -- it should be said -- have
CNN and MSNBC in which people are shouting
back and forth at one another about it.
There's much less reporting, much more just
yelling back and forth,so called commentators
so television has become - political debate
on television has become a kind of blood sport
and when it becomes that sort of blood sport,
it's much easier to use TV to incite fear.
Television isn't very good at conveying information.
It's great at provoking emotion which is why
the healthcare debate, who knows what the
healthcare plan is?
Nobody knows if you talk to people and if
you watch TV, somebody can be a news junkie
but they'll never have it defined because
television isn't good at conveying that sort
of thing.
Whether the Fairness Doctrine - I think the
return of regulation of television in the
form of the Fairness Doctrine and other things,
that of course was the entire history from
the 30's with radio all the way to the Reagan
Administration.
I think that would help certainly so the news
divisions don't have to feel that they have
to make money.
They used to be loss leaders and they used
to do a much better job but we are way beyond
that I'm afraid, unfortunately.
>> Thank you for coming and sharing this information
with us.
Mark Danner: Thank you.
>> A couple of questions.
One is you had mentioned the stat about 25
percent of Americans being opposed to torture
but 75 percent of the US is not Republican.
So I was wondering if you'd kind of comment
on that.
Like who are those people basically?
And then why are they okay with it?
The other is that growing up I always had
this perception of the United States as kind
of being the ones who take the high road.
I know that's not entirely true but that was
my perception.
Like it was what set us apart from a lot of
other countries were issues like torture and
so forth.
So I was wondering if you had a comment on
children growing up nowadays where you're
sort of inundated with this idea that actually
torture is kind of justified maybe, which
is absolutely foreign to what I grew up with.
Mark Danner: Yeah.
Well, these are all hard questions.
Those are two extremely good questions.
You are right.
75 percent of the country is not Republican
and what is most important here, and you see
this at the level of Congress as well, that
significant parts of the Democratic party
are afraid of this issue or to give them more
credit, feel strongly about it, that these
things should be used on detainees.
And I think that's reflected on the population.
It should be said by the way that that poll
was government should never torture so "never",
which you know you can imagine people answering
it in the negative by saying well we need
to have this as a possible option if the so
called "ticking bomb" scenario happens which
"24" is of course based on which we have so
far as I know never encountered but which
as a rhetorical device is extremely useful
to say what if there's a nuke?
It was planted in the middle of Manhattan
or San Francisco or whatever.
You have the guy who knew where it was, you
knew it was going to go off in three minutes.
All of these things which are completely ridiculous
but which have this way of narrowing down
the question to a tiny point.
But you are quite right that it isn't just
the Republican party, it's very true.
Your second question about the belief in America
taking the high road I think cuts to the heart
of a lot of things and it makes me sort of
quail for a second because there is this notion
and we do grow up with it in the United States.
It's not just we grow up with it, it's part
our founding ideology that the US is different.
It was founded in a different way and it was
founded on ideals of quality of all people,
quality of all men actually to be specific
but it was even at the time this ideology
was not put in practice when it came to voting
– when it came to a lot of things.
But nonetheless, that's what the country is
founded on and there goes along with that,
I think that conviction, the idea that we
are always the nice guys.
We rebuilt Europe, we just didn't rape it
and take what we wanted.
We rebuilt it and we're a country where we
don't go out and grab what we want, even though
we could.
We're all powerful but we're nice and with
that general ideology that we're above it
all which is basically what you're saying
goes a notion as well that "No more Mr. Nice
Guy", do you know what I mean?
That when we're attacked, and I saw this frequently
after 9/11, this idea of "All right, you want
to play that way, we can play that way. We
can be as tough as anyone."
I remember I did a debate shortly before the
Iraq War began with Christopher Hitchens in
Berkeley.
I was arguing against the war and he was arguing
for it.
It was January 2003 so a couple of months
before the war.
It was a packed hall, several thousand people
and I'll never forget, and this is Berkeley,
and I'll never forget at a certain point Christopher
said, "You know, at the end of the day we've
been attacked and we have to respond", which
of course alighted the fact that Saddam did
not attack us.
But nonetheless, that's what he said and I
remember on the stage feeling this sort of
surge from the audience, kind of the middle
of the audience was kind of like a lot of
frat guys and sort of athletes -- you'll forgive
me, but it's kind of what it looked like from
the stage -- and I heard this kind of [makes
a yelling rrrrr noise] in reaction, like "RRRRR.
Yeah!"
And I remember thinking it's this sort of
primal thing that "Hey, we've been nice. We
don't drop our nukes even though we have them
but you know what? It's time to get tough."
So I think that that way of thinking has its
roots in the general way I think you're saying
which is "we're the nice guys, we're above
it all" and it has a kind of slingshot effect
which is that now we are going to get tough
and dirty and we can do it as well as anyone
and I think that, in a sense, was the governing
ideology for a number of years and it's still
strong on the part of many people.
>> Hi. So I would say that on the moral issue
of whether torture is ever okay is that it's
completely legitimate to say it should never
be done but on the pragmatic issue of whether
it actually works, it seems that Obama more
than anyone else, would have been the guy
to come into the White House and say, "We're
going to end this" and even he has sort of
backed down a little bit from that, both in
rhetoric and action.
So don't you think that's it possible that
he has sort of seen the information of whether
it's been effective and reassessed his position
in pragmatic terms and said basically with
torture we have this dilemma in that we have
to trade off the public good and the individual
protections and given the new information
I have, I'm now leaning a little bit more
in the public safety, probably good direction.
Mark Danner: Mm-hmm.
It's a very good question, first of all and
as to whether I believe that that's what's
happened, the answer is no, I don't.
I think there's no evidence of that whatever.
The premise of course is that in the whole
metaphor of balancing the public good and
following the law, or moral or however you'd
like to define the anti torture position,
the premise of that of course is that torture
is the only way to get information under certain
circumstances, that it is indeed effective
and I think all evidence shows, or at least
suggests, that Obama does not believe that.
It's clear that former Vice President Cheney
does believe it fervently and one can't just
say as many writers I admire do, "Well, torture
doesn't work."
I think there is to some degree an open question
on that.
I mean, some interrogators believe it does
work but an awful lot believe it doesn't,
that it just gives bad information, that it
makes it harder to get information.
I think if you took a consensus of sort of
professionals who do interrogation, the overwhelming
majority would say this stuff doesn't work,
it's a bad idea.
However, to be honest, there's no way to judge
- the Vice President continually says, "We
would have been attacked, we would have been
attacked."
If you look at the evidence he's given to
date, it's very, very thin.
He continually says, "I have secret documents
that will prove this, but alas they're classified."
My view is that I had hoped that the Obama
Administration would essentially appoint,
boring as it sounds, a high level commission
like the 9/11 Commission for all of its flaws,
to investigate this thoroughly, to look at
what was done and what information was actually
gained, and to weigh that against the damage
that this stuff did to the country.
Because you know the war, and what you weigh
against torture is not just that it's immoral
or not just that it's illegal, which by the
way it is but the political damage you do
yourself.
Obama has talked about this frequently and
it was particularly in the context of closing
Guantanamo, and I saw this myself in Iraq,
that Abu Ghraib and Guantanamo became huge
issues throughout the Muslim world.
I mean, you see on murals on the street, hooded
man on the box with the wires, leashed men,
Lynndie England holding the leash with a naked
Iraqi prisoner on the ground sort of scrunched,
with his face scrunched in agony.
These things are extremely vivid issues in
what is, at the end of the day, a political
war.
I mean, we're not going to win this year by
killing all Jihadists.
What eventually has to happen is that the
political impetus for joining these groups,
or supporting these groups, has to be diminished
largely through political means.
And Obama, I think to his great credit, realizes
that and that's why he want to Cairo and that
is I think one of the main reasons he's been
quite outspoken about torture.
I mean, he mentions it repeatedly.
It's just when it comes to the policy side
that his administration, it seems to me, is
starting to hesitate about whether it's worth
it to push these things all the way.
But to go back to your question, I see no
evidence that he has determined that this
stuff is useful. I mean, he hasn't reinstituted
the policies so -
>> Can I follow that up with two comments,
questions?
>>Mark Danner: Sure. Yeah.
So one of them is I think that if someone
full-heartedly believed that torture would
absolutely save a thousand lives or ten thousand
lives, I think they would still, for most
people, have a big moral issue with doing
it.
So my question is if it doesn't work and if
the people who are participating in it are
not seeing any results, why is this still
a discussion that's being had?
Mark Danner: Well, let me just jump in there
quickly.
I'm certainly not arguing that everyone who
used it didn't believe it worked.
There's certainly people who believe it worked.
There's no question about that and one shouldn't
be ambivalent about answering that.
It's not just the Vice President -- there
were other people who believed it worked.
It should be said also that some people involved
in the interrogations, including some have
come out publicly, believe that it was a terrible
mistake.
So I would never stand here and say everybody
who was involved in this thinks it's a waste
of time and they shouldn't do it.
I would not argue that.
If it were true, we wouldn't really be having
this discussion.
>> And on this -- you made a point about trying
to end terrorism with politics and that sort
of thing, that I really think I disagree with
you because -
Mark Danner: I didn't say 'end'. I said 'diminish'.
>> Right, so my point is like the speech that
Obama made in Cairo was very good.
And to the best of my knowledge, there's no
evidence that anything has changed in terms
of the Islamic world is one point.
And the other point on something like Abu
Gharaib, obviously that was a disgusting thing.
I don't know the details about how much the
higher levels knew about it but it seems to
me that a lot of the Islamic world, the people
that get motivated to go out and blow themselves
up, they believe for instance that the Jews
were responsible for 9/11.
It's very widely believed that Israel wants
to be the - I don't remember the term but
that huge, big country that's ten times bigger
than Israel is what many of them believe Israel
seeks to become.
Things that are not based on any evidence
so this is just that that culture is not one
that values truth as much as it should and
so they are very easy to - they become vulnerable
to all kinds of propaganda and we, to the
best of my knowledge, even the Bush administration
and Dick Cheney were opposed to what happened
with Abu Gharaib.
Mark Danner: Well, okay, let me jump in there
because you raised a lot of points.
The first point was about the effect of Obama's
speech.
I didn't say his speech would end terrorism
or anything else.
It's obvious that terrorism will continue.
There will be more terrorism because there
was terrorism before 9/11.
It's not going to go away.
It's been with us for centuries literally
and it's very effective in some ways but I
would completely disagree with you when you
say that there's no evidence that his speech
had any effect.
Public opinion polls in much of the Muslim
world show that the sort of catastrophic fall
in the opinion of the United States has certainly
been reversed since Obama has become President.
I think the question is what would you take
as evidence for the speech having been effective?
And it seems to me incontrovertible that this
war, at the end of day, has political sources.
I mean, you pointed to a lot of them yourself
in the second part of your question which
has to do with attitudes about the United
States.
These are real things that people believe
and it makes no sense to me that in some way
changing the behavior and also the rhetoric
of the US would have no effect whatever on
people's perceptions of the US and their behavior.
Now, will it change everyone's?
Of course not, it won't.
The roots of the struggle with Al Qaeda and
you can point this out by looking at Obama's
speech itself, he talks in Cairo and it was
an eloquent speech.
I urge people who didn't see it to have a
look at it, it's very much worth looking at
but the fact remains that he was standing
there in Cairo in the shadow of one of the
autocracies that these guys
are really jazzed about, these guys meaning
Al Qaeda.
The Mubarak regime and the House of Saud,
in Saudi Arabia, are the two regimes that
they are desperate to get rid of.
Why?
Because they believe that they're an apostate,
they believe they're illegitimate, they believe
they should replaced by Islamic
governments and they having tried to remove
them directly, especially Egypt and having
been crushed by Egypt's security forces, they
then turned - that was the near enemy - they
then turned to the far enemy, the United States,
because the US is perceived as the major backer
of the House of Saud and the Mubarak regime
to which one should say the US does give two
billion dollars a year so the US is a major
backer.
So, from their point of view, you attack the
United States to try to remove these regimes.
Now, is there something we can do about that?
Well, Obama has not begun to change policy
in any way but I would say that this is a
political problem that's recognizable.
It has to do with political modernization,
which is a tendentious term, but I think it's
true when it comes to Egypt and Saudi Arabia.
It comes from a lack of representation in
those countries.
It comes from the frustration of a very youth
based population and in the case of Egypt,
a highly educated population and in the case
of Saudi Arabia, a very rich population, that
has greats frustration about not getting jobs,
about not having opportunity.
A lot of things that it seems to me you can
trace to not having governments that are in
any way representative.
I mean, Egypt has been ruled for thirty years
under a state of emergency, has a terrible
torture regime so you know during the Cold
War, the US supported autocracies in Latin
America, very similar.
How do you support political modernization
without having a Communist regime come in?
Here, how do you support political modernization
without having an Islamic regime come in?
Because if you had a free election in Egypt
or Saudi Arabia, you'd probably have an Islamic
regime and that is a real political problem.
So I don't think it just has to do with culture,
I don't think it has to do with misperceptions
but I do think it has a political answer and
I think this administration knows that and
is trying to do something about it, however
difficult it is.
>> Thanks for coming. I was wondering on the
topic of the political climate in America
and something that I've wondered is at least
five or six years ago, one absolutely unequivocal
voice that torture by Americans is wrong was
John McCain -- he is a leading figure in the
Republican party. Why didn't he ever have
any influence?
Mark Danner: [laughs] These are all extremely
hard questions.
I don't know why I'm looking at Ann but someone
has to be responsible.
You're right.
McCain had a long history of opposing torture.
He was tortured very brutally by the North
Vietnamese when he was a prisoner in Hanoi
and there's a gruesome account of that in
his memoir and in 2004 or 2005 - 2006, he
was involved very directly in trying to mitigate
these policies and he was involved directly
in the Detainee Treatment Act and the Military
Commissions Act.
And he would claim, I think, that he was responsible
for putting a stop to waterboarding, among
other things.
Whether or not that's true, I don't know but
I do remember vividly I was in Washington
to - people remember the Baker Commission?
On Iraq.
I went there to testify to it and I remember
getting up, opening the door -- they have
the newspaper waiting for you on the floor
there outside your room.
And there was the Washington Post and the
headline, I wish I could quote it verbatim
but it was "McCain's Position on Torture May
Damage Nomination Hopes", front page.
And I looked at this and thought, "Wow, what
a headline", and took the paper and read it
and the piece was this amazing piece of journalism
in which there was really no news, all it
was was people, most of them unnamed, within
the Republican party saying, "Well, you know
if John keeps after this issue, I don't know
whether he can get the nomination. The security
hawks are going to be very alienated by this."
So the whole thing was kind a letter to McCain
saying "you better hold off on this stuff
or you're going to have trouble getting the
nomination".
And I think, for political reasons, and indeed
we say that as if it's a curse, he is a politician.
I think he did hold off to some degree on
this issue, although it should be said to
be fair to him, in the Republican primary
debates - I don't know of - God, to think
of that, I wish I could get those out of my
head.
But the debates during the primaries leading
up to his getting the Republican nomination,
at one point, I don't remember where it was
but Mitt Romney sort of said, "Close Guantanamo?
We need more Guantanamos?"
More Guantanamos, more torture and Mc Cain
very aggressively took him on, on television,
and sort of said, "No, this is wrong. You
are completely wrong about this. I know about
torture."
So he still remained kind of a spokesman on
this issue throughout the campaign but I think
you're quite right, that he hasn't gone against
his party on this issue.
And I would have real respect for him if he
came out against the Vice President and criticized
him and he indeed has not done that and has
not been helpful on the Guantanamo issue either.
And I think one could speculate on whether
he's moving to the right.
He has a primary challenge in Arizona from
J.D. Hayworth and in general, he's perceived
to be moving to the right but the story of
McCain is a very interesting one when it comes
to the general issue of torture and politics
which is one of my subjects today obviously.
>> Thanks.
Mark Danner: You're welcome.
Sandy Deason: Well, that's all the time we
have for today.
Thank you so much for coming.
Mark Danner: Thank you.
Thanks everybody for coming.
[applause]
It's a pleasure.